they're cricket mad here dozens of games
in an enormous park in the centre of
kabul
looks normal enough but look closely no
women or girls no families just boys and
men a year ago the scene would have been
completely different
that's how the taliban believes it
should be women covered in public
attending to their husbands needs and
looking after the kids
the uncovered faces of female models are
painted out on buildings
the taliban basically believe women
should all but disappear from public
life
it's nonsense of course and behind the
curtain it's utterly ignored
beauty salons were initially closed but
the women owners are the main family
breadwinners so they've been allowed
back
for special occasions particularly
weddings they come for hair and makeup
they have for generations and it's not
un-islamic
but the relationship with the taliban's
morality police is tensed
[Music]
over the past 20 years a new generation
of educated and ambitious women has
grown up expecting a lot more than the
taliban's archaic sense of order
they're angry and scared but determined
we won't identify her but this 22 year
old working in her family shop is about
to finish her degree in russian
she has no intention of staying
points
my daughter is about the same age as you
she's a bit younger she works in the
fashion industry could you tell her
what your life is like
amongst the poorest sections of society
women are disproportionately affected by
the economic crisis here
this is a common sight women and
children waiting outside bakeries
wealthier customers leave extra money
and it's handed out at the end of the
day
it's demeaning and many intentionally
wear burqas to hide their embarrassment
and identity
the taliban's old guard believe this is
sustainable the new generation know
afghanistan will remain cut off and
sanctioned until it changes afghanistan
is desperate for outside help and that
may be the only hope women here have
stu ramsey sky news kabul